some great houses call us upstarts but
the truth is that while the Starks and
Lannister's fell to the Targaryen Zin
defeat house Tyrell rose for thousands
of years our family served as loyal
stewards to the kings of the reach until
the last of their line unwisely burned
to death resisting the Targaryen
invaders to save the reach from a
similar fate
we yielded the castle of Highgarden to
Aegon and his sisters in gratitude the
Targaryen gave house Tyrell dominion
over the reach and we became lords of
the castle in which for generations we
had served under the Targaryen dynasty
Westeros prospered gone were the petty
Wars of Seven Kingdoms and the endless
thirst for minor Glory's that drove them
the westerland's enriched the realm the
North guarded it and the reach and river
lands fed it this harmony is what Robert
Baratheon shattered with his rebellion
against Aerys Targaryen when the call to
arms came though we did not want to
answer the reach is a gentle land and
honestly the Mad King was not much loved
but we owed peace and status to his
family my father mace Tyrell called his
banners and marched north to battle the
rogue storm Lord Robert who had already
defeated three forces in a single day
and at Ashford my father won some chase
and my father for not pursuing Robert
after the battle we had cut him off from
the Stormlands the seat of his power and
he had fled north within easy grasp of
Lord Tywin Lannister the hand of Aerys
for 20 years my father moved instead to
lay siege to Robert's ancestral
stronghold of storms end the Rose would
strangle the stack as the lion pounced
so we waited but the Lions slumbered and
Robert slipped past the Kings forces to
join Ned Stark
we could have lifted the siege and
deployed our armies north to aid the
crown we could have stormed the walls of
the castle and made Robert homeless but
we had ample supplies control of land
and sea and most of all patience our
siege would succeed eventually at little
cost of life to us if Robert prolonged
the war with minor victories our capture
of storm's end would hasten his downfall
and if Robert won the war well it would
not do for him to find us in his halls
with the bodies of his brother Stannis
and his sworn men when the lion finally
showed his colors and purged King's
Landing
we knew our cause was lost my father
chose the peaceful route and bent the
knee to Robert who heartily pardoned us
strange considering how we'd beaten him
and starved his brother to the brink of
death we were to keep our lands Castle
in title but we knew that we would never
be welcome at court
it didn't matter the reach was still the
most fertile of the Seven Kingdoms and
under our hand every flower even the
Rose needs pruning then it grows strong